thanks for coming I'm going to pop up
the stack a little bit here talk about
some of the patterns its currency that
I've seen things that work for me and go
things that I've seen working my peers
and then more importantly things that
don't work everything I'm going to talk
about today is my opinion obviously but
I think many will agree here so I do
like soccer thanks for sask football
whatever um I've been a David's engineer
at iron taiyo for like three months or
four months of seven been writing go for
a little over a year and a half most of
that before iron was hobby projects and
such I've contributed a little bit to a
lot of things I guess a little bit of
progression of the languages I've
written I still really love c++ just
because I feel like it's more
complicated than my life so it's crazy
anyway go here really happy with go and
let's just dive into it this title here
was in the description of my talk this
is not a ding on go at all go actually
has some obviously very powerful
concurrency primitives that's one of the
biggest reasons why i love it today
though i'm going to discuss how i think
we should be using these primitives
responsibly many will disagree some will
agree i'd love to have the discussion so
i'm going to really briefly just go
ahead i'm going to touch on mutexes
channel sweet groups we all know how to
use them i'm going to just lay out a
little bit of the conventions that i use
for them i'm going to go into a little
bit more detail and timeouts how I do
cancellation how i use net context which
I'll show in a lot more detail if you
haven't heard of it and then there's a
little special topic that's kind of your
adrenal heart for select loops I'll
explain those in a lot of detail at the
very end so first of all locks they have
a time in place I've seen a lot of
literature on when to use them when not
to use them best tool for the job has
been thrown around a lot there they can
be hard to use
I just try to remember that everyone
proud remembers that when you don't have
a good convention on how to use locks
things go bad in a lot of code that I've
seen that uses channels to communicate
between go routines and then adds in a
lock or vice versa so they share memory
by communicating and communicate by
sharing memory things go back or they
can go bad generally as we all know
share memory about communicating is
preferred not required so here's what
I've sort of come up with go
specifically there's not much here
obviously when you defer unlocking even
if it's a read/write lock that's
preferable you don't have to remember
you can return multi-play TSA's etc the
second two are basically just
documentation points that last part is
important those conventions from other
languages not saying we should all use
them because there are other languages
they're not go but the really important
one here is the middle documenting
ownership and your public interface is
crucial if you're using mutual exclusion
with locks it's really really painful as
a caller to a library or as a lot of
aryan commenter to have to remember oh
do i need the guy to own this or do i
need own this before i call or vice
versa to that point if you can abstract
that mutual exclusion into a high-level
concept some kind of reservation ID or
something like that very very useful to
do here's an example there's a lot to
read here I'm going to just touch on a
few little points here this is just some
generic interface that I came up with
it's modeled after some code that I've
written it iron the basic idea is this
is a map string to whatever value you
want and instead of passing channels
back in this case instead of requiring a
mutex to be passed in or requiring
ownership before someone calls one of
the functions in this interface we just
have this concept called reservation ID
the reservation ID is just a little
cookie that you get indicating that you
have ownership they can be expired with
this guy and they
not exist you can pass in a random old
string and you'll get an error a few key
points here we talk about what's going
to happen if you don't have reservation
here we talk about what happens if you
are able to acquire the reservation we
talk about what happens if the
reservation is not already held there's
a few other things here but the primary
goal of this illustration here is to
tell the user what's going to happen if
they don't own it what's going to happen
if they do own it and what's going to
happen after the action takes place the
action in this case is the function
called moving on channels I'm going to
go through some of these primitives a
little quickly here we all know how to
use channels in conjunction with go
routines a lot of us know really well
how do you select select as awesome as
well I read and heard somewhere from a
lot of different people that channels
and lower teens don't really matter
unless you have select I agree
completely agree particularly for
channels here they're built in to go for
a reason so let's try to use them by
default a lot of times when I've written
programs I fall back to the sea days and
I say oh let me get pthread lengthy
threaded this is go there's no pthread
but we do have sink mutex I try to
convince myself why I shouldn't use
mutexes or read write lock and why I
should use channels oftentimes for me as
a relatively new go programmer one and a
half ish years I have to flip my
thinking around a little bit it's that
whole thing about sharing memory but
communicating instead of the vice versa
so some conventions it's really really
nice as a user of a library to know when
I make a function call that takes in a
channel or return to channel what's it
going to do with that channel inside I
don't really want to have to go look in
the code although i do but it's really
nice to know that in the documentation
shows up on go doc or very nice thing to
have secondly very similar point when we
enlist the compiler by using directional
channels we can get the compilot or tell
us things about how our program will
not behave right when we build it not
after running a writing test so for
example the compiler will not let you
close a read-only channel and I've shown
example of what channel a directional
channel looks like in a second last two
points there we all know about clothes
we know what happens when we're trying
to read from a closed Channel you know
how to range over channels so that the
clothes etc etc that one probably
doesn't need a lot of explanation the
second and last one there in case you
don't know what a generator is a
generator is a function that returns a
channel but starts up a go routine
inside of it to interact on that channel
really in my experience that's the only
useful thing to do in a function that
returns a channel there are others but
that's the real only widely used
practice the reason is because if you
return a channel from a function and
that function expects to do some
interaction on the chat oh you might get
a deadlock it might be very easy to get
a deadlock because if function is doing
something on the channel you haven't
gotten it back to listen or write to
that channel it's kind of ill defined by
default what's going to happen because
the library author hasn't told you
what's going to happen go defines it
very well but the library author may not
have so here's a little bit of an
example this is taken from ID tracking
system for incoming requests to a
service it's a little bit abstract but
it proves doesn't prove shows the point
a little bit if you don't know
directional channel are there sorry it's
a right only channel so that means watch
changes will only be able to write on
that channel we talk about what happens
if the request is reserved and watch
changes we talked about what happens in
interaction on that channel you pass the
watch changes you talk about
specifically what happens in the
interaction of that channel what an
error is returned anata no errors return
and then a similar thing here we talked
about what happens with the weight group
which I'll touch on in a second we
talked about what happens when that
weight group will be done we talked
about what happens with this generator
functions channel we've talked about
what happens with general
your functions internal go routine that
interacts on that channel that one's
very important and then finally I've
talked to Todd about documentation that
part is over now you don't have to read
as much I will focus a lot more on
writing code but this little point right
there don't let go to be empty that's
very important it's kind of
heartbreaking when I go to a go doc page
and see nothing I just see a bunch of
function declarations that's really
great go doc is an amazing tool when I
don't have Coke what I don't have
documentation I you should click into
the functions I look at the code I
understand how libraries working but
that takes on the order of 10 times more
it's an order of magnitude longer for me
to understand how to use library that it
would if there was simple documentation
it doesn't even have to be as much as
this or this but just a little hint
what's going to happen with the channels
when do I have ownership so on and so
forth that means the world just keep
that in mind if you're writing any kind
of reusable code at all even if it's
inside of your company even if its code
that you don't think might be reusable
or will be reusable it still is very
important even for yourself as you come
back three days later so on to wait
group a common use of for wait group is
to just notify when something's done
it's a good way to gather a bunch of go
routines together as we all know no one
there all finished that's common we know
that there's a couple other things that
I've used it for before I list them here
the last one is underappreciated in my
opinion when you are writing tests on
functions of functionality that has a
lot of concurrency going on it's very
useful to be able to make those tests
deterministic it sucks run and go test
twice time in one failure in one success
I'll touch on a little more a little bit
more how to do this but when you have a
test that waits for a weight group to be
done before it continues doing its
testing that can be very very useful for
you is the test writer and obviously
very useful for me as the test runner
so pretty simple explanation here sorry
pretty simple code example here this is
just notification inside of a for select
loop really just a for loop endless
inside of a girl routine it notifies the
collar of start loop when the first
thing has been done in the loop so you
can imagine this might be good in the
test if this is doing for it since some
IO making an HTTP request to your handle
or something like that it can be really
nice in the test for you to wait group
that wait once the way it has returned
you've done the first iteration of the
loop is finished now you can check your
handler you can figure out it past the
right body is the body in JSON decodable
etc etc etc and that's instead of just
time sleeping in your tests and hoping
that the test the sleep well we'll
return after the first iteration of that
loop is completed in that case you're
relying on the schedule or schedule
disco routine before your time sleep is
up and a few other things so on and so
forth so now I'm going to move on this
is a little bit more complicated example
we all know about fannin if you don't
know about fannin I really highly
encourage you to go read Rob's talk here
about concurrency it's a round slide 28
I think it's 28 through 32 or 33 can
just go to that link fannin is a really
really powerful tool because it's a very
very easy way to understand how to do
concurrency we No Go is very good at
concurrency if you can do it here if the
semantics of your program allows it you
should do it there's no excuse not to i
define fan here though as both a code
pattern that is shown and Rob's talk and
I'll show in a second but also it's a
series of steps that you could follow to
take your sequential code and convert it
into concurrent code so there's another
section that's really good under the go
blog you can read up under the fan out
fan in section of pipelines really what
fan and boils down to here though is
it's a weight group and a few channels
you put those two together in the right
way it's pretty understandable
so we'll start with our poor function
that doesn't really do any kind of
current computation imagine we just have
a datastore we simulate the datastore
here by sleeping for a random number of
milliseconds up to a second and then we
were just returned a random integer I'll
prove to you that this does stuff takes
a while this might be the demo effect
nope okay so yeah you know we did bunch
of random dangers we took about five
seconds so it's about right we slept
randomly okay now there's a lot of bold
here this is these are the things we've
changed in order to a do this
concurrently and be keep our public
exported interface the same so if you
follow along here that first function is
Justin utility basically add it so I can
fit all the code on the slide we're
getting a weight group that adds ten to
it after we create it before we return
it we're getting a channel int once we
go into our loop we're doing the same
thing we're doing ten datastore queries
inside of each loop we make a channel
our new data store get function now
takes in a channel and closes it after
it says the result back from the channel
so again we're doing our random sleep to
simulate our datastore function we're
setting the result back but the key here
is the closed signal remember I
mentioned that before it comes in handy
here we spawn a new little girl routine
to wait for our guide to be done and
pass it back to the main channel the
main channel being CH the top and then
after we exit all of our loops and
actually there's a little bug here I
should have passed the sea in here
apologies for that at the end of our
whole deal we have one goroutine that's
waiting for all the guys to be done
that's waiting this WG wait and then we
close our main channel closing the main
channel now it allows us to have a
pretty simple range here the range will
stop as we know once CHS closed and
pretty simple when we get each integer
back regardless of the order in which
they come back we put it into our slice
and now we can return them just the same
as we did before so bug and all let's
run this so now we did our 10 and a
little
second the bug effect here is that where
I was probably most likely going to be
listening on the wrong channel actually
I take that back or not because it's in
closing the loop sorry demo effect again
but in my brain okay so that's fan and
fan out there's kind of a little group
list of steps when I go back here when I
see something like this when I see some
io for instance almost ours is IO when I
CIO happening inside of a loop it's
sequential I immediately just started
licking my lips and I go okay we can
write a little bit more code here but we
get this huge speed up we got onto an
order of magnitude speed up here 5x
betta when I run this in gold max prox
equals 4 it's about an order of
magnitude that's really great this is
not been much more code to get that done
so do it I'm going to move on to
production issues this will be pretty
similar to the fan and fan out but we're
talking now about long-running systems
okay issues are always going to happen
in long-running systems we have flaky
hardware with running in the cloud
potentially we've got bad networks we're
setting out across the internet etc etc
etc disks whatever some bigger shops or
you if you're really really ambitious
you'll be able to write some
infrastructure to test long-running
systems it's actually something we're
working on right now if you have the
infrastructure use it test your
long-running systems whatever language
that written see what happens long-term
try to put way more data than it expects
into it trying to crash one of the nose
etc etc but even if you can't here are
some ways to be proactive in your
program to try and fail it gracefully
try and make it a little bit more more
robust to those issues so first of all
time outs there's a really really
trivial program that i wrote to
illustrate this it's like starting at a
girl routine that listens on
that never gets sent on and waiting for
that channel the reason I wrote it
though is to illustrate here that if you
don't time out on channel waits in your
real production system you might end up
in something like this this is kind of
crappy to see if you have your little
log aggregator at 2am you have to wake
up and you see this it's just like I
could have prevented that and my I
always think that in my head that could
have been prevented an easy way to
overcome it just do is select remember
selects they're really nice just select
on that channel and select on a time or
two cases and your select and make the
time or something reasonable have it
timeout after a second a seconds a long
time but at least it's not this there's
also one better we can do that is net
context there's a blog post on the goal
line blog apologies for not including
the link to it here but it's a big blog
post on Wynette context why Google uses
it like a lil created it how we will use
it very great blog posts just google for
it Google's pretty easy to find I kind
of cheated here though in my avocation
for net context because in the top
description I said that everything would
be done in the standard library this is
not in the standard library really cool
if it was but it's not but you could
build it in the standard library in like
a couple hours maybe and that would
include tests it's so important here in
my experience is so important that I'm
putting it in this talk even though I
have to make excuses to do that so
here's the interface copyright and all I
hope I got that right guys so I took out
all comments the comments are excellent
this is another good example for how to
write comments but essentially this is
this context interface can be
constructed in multiple different ways
can have a context that never said
done it's called a background context
you can have a context that you can
cancel and then it will send undone you
can have a context that can timeout or
you can cancel it and most importantly
here is that you can build a tree out of
these contexts you can create a
cancellation contacts out of another
context that if the first context the
parent of the tree is cancelled then the
child of the tree will also be cancelled
you can imagine how a large coat large
code base that would really be nice to
represent collar and collie
relationships so let's talk about
context as they might be in a
distributed system there is a Jeff Deane
talk I originally saw it at recon 2013
he wrote a paper on it I think
beforehand he's behind a paywall so I
couldn't include the link it talks about
a lot of practical things about how they
run distributed systems at Google you
might imagine those are big distribute
systems but they've run for a long time
so it's pretty good guy to listen to one
of the interesting parts of this paper /
talk is called hedge request has
requests are on the cover pretty simple
you just do a bunch of get requests that
are they don't have side effects think
they're idempotent they don't do
anything to a datastore so on and so
forth you do a bunch of them to bunch
back ends that are all identical and
when the first one returns the
simplified version you just cancel the
rest of them you get a lot more I Oh
obviously if you're running the backend
over a network it's a lot more network
he has a really good study they did in
real in real life I'm how it affects
network what the trade-off is between
the network and the speed of their
services the long tail encourage you to
look at that Rob showed a pretty good
variant of that in the same concurrency
patterns you can see a theme here he
flied 50 of that same concurrency
patterns talk encouraging to go look at
that i'm going to add on to that one
extra part which is the cancellation so
remember here we talked about making a
bunch of get requests it's great you can
just grab the first one that comes back
but what about the other ones if the
back
that you're doing and get on consuming
resources then it would be nice to me
like canceling if for instance they're
doing some crypto or they're accessing
another back end or they're doing a scan
on disk or something like that if you're
able to cancel them you could
potentially be saving a lot of resources
so here's what it looks like adding
cancellation using net context let me
just run this the first so what this is
what this is doing is saying i will give
you on the third line there i will give
you 10 milliseconds to get something
done we're going to start up ten little
getters here and go routines get is a
simulation of a network call it's going
to sleep for some random amount of time
less than or equal to 100 milliseconds
and then it's going to send back on CH
channel it's going to send back its
result which is just a random integer so
you can see in this first little part
there's a chance that we might that
might not get anything back and by the
way the random number generators in all
this are actually seated with the
current time so we will actually get
results back so we're getting their
results back no result now we get a
result now we get no result get results
so you can see that sort of
non-determinism what would you do in a
system like this if you start getting no
results back well you can do one or two
things you could wait for longer which
is just a little config value will plug
it into whatever config system you want
or you can increase the number of gets
both have trade-offs but both are
tunable there's no extra code you have
to write if you do this right you don't
have to deploy any new code at all just
tuna value here and there and then again
at the end here read the way that we're
out putting this output we've got a
little select we're either waiting on
the channel to return from one of those
or we're waiting on the done so the done
will get sent after 10 milliseconds one
of these will happen before the other
and it once that happens we do our
little print and we die additionally the
get function will also listen
thumb if it gets a context done it stops
at closes is that's it the girl routine
is dead but there's a lot more we can do
that he talks about in his talk and
paper one of the things he talked about
is waiting until 95th percentile latency
and then start sending the other
requests that's when the alarms go off
that's when you should start trying to
get other things you can do that pretty
easily with two contexts one context for
the first one and for that first get and
have that context be sent to the 95th
percentile latency if that context fires
is done and you haven't got a result
back create another context that's
cancellable once you create the
cancellable context you can now issue
that to n other gets once you've done
that if one of those returns you're good
if not now it's time to wake up at 2am
or do something better hopefully do
something better the second thing
obviously we talked about canceling
in-flight requests well he goes a step
further and talks about sending the
cancellation all the way to all the way
down to the back end at the back end
calls very simple you just pass the
context or some representation thereof
across the wire if you're doing network
hall or down to a subsystem if you're
doing it that way the context can be go
can go anywhere inside of a go program
and it always max the same you will
always send on that done channel when
the timeout happens or when is canceled
remember we can build trees of it so the
guy who receives it if it's a back-end
that I've been calling it back in if the
backend receives it he can choose how
long he wants to wait and that's
completely independent from the guy who
called that back in and then finally
this one I find pretty interesting he
talks about Target to target
communication so if I'm sending out to
10 different backends I can also send
those back in some information about all
the other guys who have asked and those
backends can coordinate amongst
themselves he doesn't detail how you can
imagine some possible coordinates
coordination algorithm
back there those guys say hey I'm done
I'm going to tell all the other guys in
this case all their nine guys that I'm
done and they shouldn't bother anymore
they can actually cancel each other and
you can obviously imagine we've got this
context tool each one of those guys can
create their own context and send it to
the other guys so now they all know
about each other now they cannot cancel
each other now we don't have to send
those extra network calls over the wire
to cancel the remaining nine because
they just do it themselves and finally
putting all these ideas together we
talked about Wade groups we've talked
about channels we talked about our force
that we talked about not for select
loops yet we talked about context for
select loops are a way that I've seen to
put them all together and they can be
very powerful when you put all these
concepts together so first of all what
are they you can do a lot of things with
four select loops you can run ago you
can run an event loop or multiple event
loops and different girl routines you
can do some kind of clean up this is not
go garbage collection but it could
potentially be compacting a log or
recycling connections or so on and so
forth you can even do things like
simulate an actor may not be a very
popular thing to do but you can do it
you can have a channel that you send to
mutate state and you can receive to get
the results of the mutation and so on
and so forth so the mechanics you run a
big loop in a goroutine it's pretty
simple I had to cut the top inside the
loop this is the Select part of the for
select you select on two more channels
for each iteration when you get a result
send for one of those channels you do
something and you send the result back
to somewhere doesn't have to be the
caller center of the channel but it can
be and then sometimes for select
operations can pass on the work that
they receive to another guy and
potentially passing context down to that
guy or channel for instance that will
return a result back to the original
Oscar if you will of the work so before
I get the code a few patterns here again
for testability is very nice to have
act system in your for select blue it's
going to be running forever but it may
not be very introspective it's very nice
if you ask the for select loop to do
some work it may respond before the work
is done but it can be very useful
especially for your testing but also for
some things like like I say rate
limiting and back pressure it can be
very useful to have an app so for
example intestine let's take that it's a
simple example you submit your work to
be done it responds to you saying I
started but you have a external channel
or an external Waker potentially that
will be done or be sent on once the work
is done maybe once it started maybe with
some progress indication and your tests
can follow along to make sure a progress
is being made be the right result has
been sent back see it's been done and
reasonable amount of time so on so forth
same thing if you're for select loop is
some kind of an event loop or a timer if
you're ticking then you want to make
sure to wrap your ticker in a knack I'll
explain a little bit more about that a
second probably by now you know I'm a
big fan of net context so you probably
want to use that for neck for
cancellation again with these signals
for the last point here it's very nice
to have signals again once your loop is
started most importantly once it stopped
in production for instance if you have a
long-running select loop perhaps it's
doing something in the background is the
result of getting some requests from
HTTP server it'd be really nice to know
if that loop is stopped because your
HTTP server may still be responding to
requests but the real work is not being
done anymore so it'd be nice to crash
the server send an alarm whatever so
here's an example of a polar we do a lot
queuing at our nephew so this would be a
pretty good example for us this is
excerpt from some code that we have this
is a for select loop you can see instead
of gorging we have our four and we've
got to select this little guy is a
simulation of a DQ so we're pulling the
queue every five milliseconds and we're
dq'ing some data just says element
random integer on it on the end there
and we're just doing that until we get
our done so if we get our done we're in
the middle of DQ the next time we're not
gonna do any more DQ's you can imagine
extrapolate this out to any number of
operations that need to be repeated
checking a file checking a timer sending
a message doing cron whatever it could
be a lot of different things here a few
other extra notes here we've got two
signals we've got 14 * and actually we
have 24 end here and i'll explain what
the deal is with both of those we've got
our to wait groups one for start and end
we've got our channel that we're
listening on we've also closing that
channel when the for select loop dies so
for if for any reason this for loop dies
doesn't look like it might hear but you
might be able to you might end up adding
something to it later or so on and so
forth both the chatter will be closed
and the weight group will be done those
are two very useful signals that you may
want to use and then here's the little
driver that I wrote for the polar this
one's actually runnable you can see here
we're just going again we're setting up
10 different Polar's we're waiting for
the polar to start we're consuming from
the Polar's channel and when we're done
consuming from Channel we're done here
we're just doing the same thing but for
all the Polar's we're Fanning them all
in again and then here since I did
enough room print Chan is just that
range over the main channel once it's
done what's the range returns we're done
it just prints out everything until it's
done so here's our results from doing
this run for 10 milliseconds we just
DQ'd a bunch of stuff until 10
milliseconds or up fairly
straightforward very fairly simple the
real power here is in our for select
loop I've seen these things that
expanded out till of 18k statements each
one of which is responding to a signal
from some other girl routine responding
to a ticker something else there's a
million different
Thanks going on here one of them I even
saw it was trying to add randomness by
modding the UNIX nano time by 68 or
something like that I don't know why but
it did it and it's pretty easy to add it
is just another case stick so then a
couple notes about this polar I didn't
put a kin for each individual operation
to go back here each individual DQ
operation we don't have a knack for it
you can imagine the act might be easily
done with a channel send but we also
have a utility at iron that as act two
timer well two timers and two tickers a
few other things those acts are
implemented basically as just passing a
funk across the channel and the guy in
the in the selic it will just call the
funk whatever happens in the funk
happens doesn't matter the only contract
is the funk will never block that allows
us to step out different different
tickers and timer implementations it
allows us to do counters in the funk to
count number of Acts allows us to gather
statistics so on and so forth I'm
leaving that as an exercise to the
reader but we might be open sourcing
something fairly soon and then I'm just
going to wrap up so go has some pretty
good currency stuff we all know that
we've all seen it I hope here that I've
just kind of illustrated some better
patterns on top of those maybe not
better but some patterns to think about
at least on top of those i think that
with things like this more talks like
this if you guys can give them with more
posts on new patterns things like this i
think we're going to finally start
building some new patterns and
conventions on top of the great stuff we
already have and go and i really really
look forward to seeing that so let's
just see here usenet context and this
this talk that i referenced is Rob's
talk it's called go concurrency
go concurrency patterns really concurred
you guys to go check that out that's it
thank you again well I true questions
hi so I found here your example a
beautiful venue I'm just wondering how
do you we have to decide speed as you
choose it's a very good question usually
when I write something like a prototype
it I do the simple way and its really
slow takes 10 seconds or something like
that premature up you know about
premature optimization root of all evil
and all that stuff I wouldn't go and
make something more complicated until
you know profile you see nice slow if
you find that you're really not moving
that much higher this really doesn't
take that long that's pretty much a
sample of that thanks to your question
okay it's a tough call to make because
yeah and triple the side of the code or
thereabouts so my decision process
really is just a drew I just go in and I
profile I say are these days start
causing ain't necessary and B column
detail relatives Chris my bro it's a
tough call to make to add more code but
my hope is that that pattern is
recognizable enough to look across all
the code base and see hey i know this is
doing and all this should look and I
cannot
it's kind of a sec do for ya okay thank
you